Music Music I'm going to get my own thoughts I'm going to
say that Everything is I'm going to feel free to hear my
thoughts I don't know why the sky is dark, the world is
where?
The world is my hand in my hand.
It's the most important thing.
I remember my memories every time.
I remember you to protect me.
In my back to the world, I once again, I won't let you talk
about the memories I'm gonna give you a dream of a dream To
the next moment It's a promise to you It's a promise It's a
sign of your life A sign of your life A dream
A sign of your dream For you
For the world And the world With the dream that's the most
beautiful I'm gonna go to the future I'll be there So-soules
Goals Over the old age Fruits Puts Puts Turgatory The world
I imagine Oh No Again I'm gonna hate you I'm gonna say You
know I'll come back to your future Go away I'll come back
I'll come back To your future Breaking out Yeah Breaking out
Breaking down Go away I'm not giving up LUSBANETA LUSBANETA
I'm not the free-for-all Not the strength The strength The
glider I've found the people The power of the human The
power of the world
For the world For the For the
The first, the The moment of my dream I've been able to
remember you.
I'm always there.
I'll be able to catch up and fly.
I'll be able to fly.
Rain too.
If you're even if I forget even though I forget even though
we're all gonna be there.
No, no, no, we're gonna get hurt.
We're gonna get away from the for you to eat out for the
time of time.
From here,
from here, from here, from here to the beginning.
A few weeks ago, now, a few days ago, I'm sure that I've
been given to you.
It's this promise that the light will be the sign of the
world.
The world, the world, the world, For you, for the end of the
day And at the end of the day I'll make you cry, I'll cry,
I'll keep it all, I'll keep it all, I'll move to the future
I'll be able to tell you